hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and yes welcome to the
first ever mkbhd youtube giveaway
so what i have for you guys here today
is a giveaway of the ifrogs air
pollution custom fallout headphones
so here's how the giveaway works guys
there's only two rules the first of
which is that you have to be a
subscriber of this youtube channel very
simple
the second part of the giveaway yeah you
guessed it leave a lowercase i before
your comment and you know feel free to
be creative with this one i like to make
giveaways sort of fun so yeah go ahead
and leave a lowercase i before your
comment below this video
so this giveaway is all about
customization so i want you right now to
go right click and open the link in the
description in a new tab and check out
how ridiculous you can make your ifrog's
fallout's headphones because if you do
win ifrogs is going to ship the
headphones and everything you tell me to
put on them directly to you so you get a
chance to see how fast i frog shipping
is and you'll get your very own pair of
completely custom eye frogs fallout
headphones and as you can see by a
couple of photos i'm going to show you
guys
you can make them pretty ridiculous make
them match your style make them flow
with your outfit so yeah definitely go
check that out
the last part of this giveaway is going
to be extra entries so if you really
want some extra entries into this
giveaway i'm going to be posting some uh
some subtle hints onto twitter and you
can follow me on twitter at mkbhd i'll
be posting some subtle little hints
about how some lucky individuals can win
some extra entries and i'll be posting
these daily uh every day some few people
will get a few extra entries into the
giveaway and hopefully will increase
their chances of getting these sweet
custom fallout headphones so uh good
luck to you and thanks for watching this
little giveaway video and i hope that
the winner of this video gets a chance
to post an unboxing of their new ifrog's
custom headphones and if you guys just
want to leave your eye comment with
something about what uh you know what
colors you would use feel free to do
that too so thank you for watching and
i'll catch you guys in the next video
peace
accounts created after the date of the
upload this video are not a little
engineer